I'll get there I'll get there I'll get
there you don't don't jump again and
just before I start you know feel free
to ask questions during the talk you
know I'm an economist and economists
have a very interactive style of
presentations and talks if you if I
don't hear questions if you don't
interrupt me then of I'll feel fed and
depressed so please don't wait until the
very end
all right so how did I get here so
that's how I got here this morning this
is what my commute looked like you know
fortunately I did make it on time but
that's basically a site of familiar to
most of you right so I got here from
Stanford and the road congestion is a
major problem and what makes this
problem sort of particularly interesting
to me it's Universal right there are
problems are things that you know is a
first world problem there are problems
that you think of as you know developing
nations problem this is you know this is
the human condition right as of 2019
everywhere in the world right from the
richest places in the world or the
poorest places in the world and you know
regulate there's all over the world have
tried all kinds of things to fix this
and so far as far as I can tell they
failed miserably worldwide okay so you
know those of you who commute regularly
you know this picture is not and it's
you know it's very familiar all right so
that's you know the one picture
motivation for why I'm working on this
now oh and by the way I completely
forgot to say this I should have this is
joint with Michael Schwartz who is at
Microsoft and who I think many of you
know and who I think will be here
actually for the next not session but
block all right so
there is good news with we hope and our
conjecture our guess is that there are
three very important emerging
technologies that will transform
transportation will hopefully help us
fix the picture that I just showed you
I'm not saying these are the only three
technologies right there you know flying
cars there are scooters really all kinds
of stuff people are working all kinds of
interesting things but we think for road
transportation for cars these three are
going to be essential one is
self-driving cars that's something you
hear about in the news all the time so
I'm not gonna spend too much time
talking about that you know happy to
talk offline I bought sort of my views
on where this is going but there are
other two technologies that are at least
as important prop possibly more
important for relieving congestion and
those are frictionless time-dependent
tolls and convenient and efficient
carpooling and by the way the curb the
carpooling part is the sort of the
matching part off of the paper the
tall's is going to be more like general
equilibrium but given that as a matching
workshop so if you're looking for the
matching part that's the third bullet
point here and the question we're after
is you know what will a market powered
by these technologies look like how
should we design and organize it what
should be the role for the regulator
what should be the role for private
parties for ubers lifts or you know new
companies that may emerge in this space
and I'll show you some some of those
potential new entrants all right and
sort of by necessity what half of my
talk is gonna be sort of head waving and
I'll get to math you know so don't if
you want math then don't despair but the
first or half of the talk I'm going to
be mostly motivating you know why we're
doing things we're doing and why we're
doing it the way we're doing them all
right so but before I even go there I
need to elaborate on why I'm talking
about tools and car pooling as emerging
technologists right so your reaction may
be why am I talking about them and it's
kind of future tense you know what would
you have them and my claim is we really
don't and here's what I mean the first
let's talk about tolls this is
what Paul's look right now this is the
current technology and this you know I
like local pictures this is the Bay
Bridge right if you want to go to San
Francisco tonight or tomorrow this is
you will pass through this and this is a
toll collection facility right so
obviously you know putting something
like that on a road is incredibly
expensive it slows down traffic and we
only have very few of those right so in
particular even if you just restrict the
tension to bridges in the Bay Area right
these are kind of the prime places to
put those things on we'll only have them
in one direction right so when I took
the Bay Bridge this morning and coming
here I did not have to pass through it
because it's too expensive and for the
purposes of raising revenue they
correctly figured out that you know it's
enough to charge people once so that's
correct but if your goal is to have
tools that are time dependent that are
trying to you know move people around to
earlier times later times well this only
works in one direction right so for the
commute from San Francisco back to
Berkeley there is no way right now to
use tall's to control that and if you
want to do that you have to build one of
those things okay so it's incredibly
expensive incredibly inconvenient so we
have very very very few of them okay so
we really don't have tolls by and large
except in some very very specific rare
places now what's changing now and when
I say now is very very soon so this
slide is from 2016 from the Singapore
land authority and they promised to have
this by 2020 and yesterday I went to
their website to check is you know there
are a lot of these things they're always
four years ahead turns out they're still
saying it's gonna happen in 2020 and now
they even have pictures of what the
system will look like what the devices
on the car so it really look like it's
happening and singing as Singapore is
one of the pioneers in road tolls and
what they're doing and this is gonna be
happening everywhere is they're
switching to a next generation road
pricing system where each car has a chip
in it or
kind of a device and then this device is
being tracked through GPS technology or
camera technology right so there is a
combination of kind of tracking and/or
taking pictures of license plates to see
where the cars are now this raises all
kinds of privacy concerns especially
into all the CS people here but you may
be able to design this is not gonna be
part of my talk you may be able to
design some cryptographic protocols to
be able to charge correct amounts
without sort of really revealing where
that car went if you're really concerned
about that I don't think Singapore is
too concerned about that but they can
see that in the es we may be more
concerned anyway so why is this special
what makes us different well obviously
putting together a system like that is
hard it's very expensive Eric it's
remind acquires in a major overhaul of
lots of things but once it's installed
once you've paid the fixed cost once
then the marginal cost of charging tolls
for any given road segment becomes zero
or essentially zero as you still need to
figure out pricing but it's close to
zero so now suddenly once this is around
which is again very very very soon this
is 2020 you will be able to charge tolls
everywhere on every road segment and
really control the entire network
through it all okay so that's why I talk
about tolls in future tests but the
future is very very close all right okay
so then the another one that you think
of as existing technology is carpooling
right so the technology for carpooling
is actually very old and very primitive
if a car has two seats you just put the
second next me or another person next to
you
you're carpooling we're done so to be
more precise what we're talking about
you know in future tense is carpooling
matching technology right the technology
for identifying good carpooling partners
right so when you see a picture like
this right that I started with without
the mathematical proof you know that
there are lots of people going in the
same direction so there are probably
when you see such a huge amount of
congestion there are probably lots of
people who would be happy to carpool at
that moment in time and they're not
because right now we don't actually
one of the really actually have a good
technology for finding convenient
carpooling partners okay they're also
not enough incentives to do it but that
I'll get to that in a moment so what's
happening right now there are lots of
companies lots of startups trying to
minimize the friction involved in
identifying good carpooling partners so
the one on the left is ways that they're
trying to leverage and on top of their
mapping technology and navigation
systems the one on the right is scoop
they're trying to do it based on people
who work together and then they sort of
fix one end of the trip you know that
it's gonna be convenient they're
resolved trust issues this way because
people who work in the same place trust
each other so then that's how they try
to solve this problem and then there is
blah blocker who is taking yet another
approach they start with real a
long-distance carpooling so they're
based in Europe and when if you have a
real a long-distance carpool you know
trip you may go through the effort of
finding a good carpooling partner then
they're trying to make this and a
shorter and shorter so this was
happening in right now you know there's
still very much work in progress all of
them but you know hopefully that will
happen soon all right so this is you
know this is the occupational hazard of
teaching in a business school you start
putting together pictures like that but
here it's actually substantive so all of
these three things that I'm talking
about they're very much driven by you
know developments in your computer
science information technology and all
of those things and it's sort of kind of
self-evident for all of the work may be
self but should be clear to many of you
why each of them is sort of nice and
interesting and potentially important
what may be less evident and that's what
I'm going to spend the next few minutes
on is that they're all highly
interdependent
okay so self-driving cars are gonna make
both tolls and car pooling more
necessary and more attractive and then
told and carpooling really strongly
reinforce each other okay so this is and
I'll get to all of those slides
and here it's important for me to pause
and emphasize one thing that suppose
self-driving cars never materialised
right it's like ten years from now we'll
look back we'll never meet like in our
lifetimes we'll look back and say okay
it was just a pipe dream
we'll never learn how to make a left
turn so we had to give up on the whole
technology so you know that's out of the
picture so our framework is actually
going to be relevant just for this
bottom part right so if you only have
tolls and carpooling together we still
have some interesting things to say but
it's actually easier from the modeling
point of view to think about
self-driving cars and the reason is that
all the passengers are kind of symmetric
okay so this is a more simple coalition
formation game you don't need to figure
out who is the driver and so forth can a
mathematical notation and all the
exposition I'm gonna think about
self-driving cars so there is no driver
everyone is a passenger but just keep in
mind if you want to apply this and some
setting where you only you don't have
self-driving car you don't have tools
and carpooling it's not hard to adapt
our model okay all right so let me start
talking about these green arrows one by
one you know why we think that one
should think about these things in a
unified framework rather than separately
so first let's think about what's the
connection between autonomous
transportation and carpooling alright so
your first image when you think about
self-driving cars it's all like that
that's a nice thing I get in the morning
I get in the car I read the newspaper
and you know it takes me to work and you
can do that but more generally once you
have self-driving cars once you take a
driver out of the equation the line
between driving solo and public
transportation become becomes completely
blurred right there is no longer a sharp
line so right now the reason why there
is a sharp line is that humans are
expensive okay so if you have any kind
of public transportation vehicle train
bus you know you name it and your horse
carriage you have a human operating them
and humans times is expensive right and
so most public transportation options
involve
a human who's caused a spread across a
lot of other people right so you have
large buses with large patio with a
large number of those Mia stops become
slow it becomes unconvenient you can't
have it go to every person's house now
if you take the cost of the driver out
of the equation suddenly it becomes
feasible to have two people sort of bus
as four people buses six people buses
right so suddenly there is no longer a
sharp line between solo driving and
taking public transportation in
particular we can you know dry write
solo on the way to work when maybe
you're riding in an unusual time so
there is not there are not that many
options for carpooling but then you're
riding back together with four other
people okay so suddenly all of these
things become much more national yes
[Music]
I'll get to that I'll get up but that's
actually much much cheaper like if you
do that if you do the maths or humans
are more expensive than stuff we'll get
to that okay so what matters and again
we'll get to there's no but I by the way
I want to take it now so and if for sure
we'll have to take the cost of the
physical cost of the equipment into
account and we will but it actually
doesn't really matter who oh I mean it
matters for contracts and for legal
reasons who owns that for economic
reasons it doesn't matter whether you
own it and you sublease it to me or the
government owns it there is just some
physical cost of wear and tear someone
has to pay for it and then you know
obviously looking like liability that
you know legal stuff needs to figure out
but it's not yeah but we'll have we'll
have C of T which is going to be very
much that yes
hugely expensive yeah you will
it's just the numbers will change a
little bit in fact what may what may end
up being different there is you'll see
was going to be critical again as I said
is is this component right is this
pairing so there in fact if your view is
that humans are cheap or free and cars
are expensive then you can think of our
frame workers we're already in the
self-driving car world all right if
you're willing to say that the cost of a
driver is zero then our frame will just
apply is automatically so it's actually
even better for developing countries
right so you don't even need to wait for
self-driving cars no but but that's like
I mean that's actually a fair point one
of and in fact for some countries as you
know as I'm sure you know where humans
are really cheap you do have sort of
self-driving cars people have drivers
right and then when they go to work you
know the driver takes them there then
they you know wait for them then they
drive them back so essentially people
have that people already have that
experience so yeah size is like 200
people right actually doesn't go away he
waits for the owner yeah but that's big
but that's big that's because humans are
free so part of the reason why you don't
you don't see those intermediate
solutions now get to this is you don't
have tools I'll get to that I'll get the
salad I'll talk about this in green I'm
talking about this green arrow now I'm
going to talk about that one and then
this is going to be very important okay
so so gasoline it's not it's not quite
the same as tall because it's the same
because the cost of gasoline is the same
throughout the day what's important
about tall's is you can make them free
in the middle of the night and you can
make them very expensive during rush
hour right and so in particular we can
start having things like people shifting
to earlier and late later departure
times which you cannot do with gasoline
okay so I'll get to that
okay yes there will be fewer vehicles on
the road if you were running cars I
think it's just that we will be instead
have more vehicles on the road which is
I'll get there again tolls are gonna be
critical I'm gonna get told they're
gonna be absolutely critical but tolls
by themselves are now gonna be the
solution so I'm gonna get there okay and
they will help kind of elaborate the
system all right
so I'm gonna skip actually and I think
we already talked about this quite a bit
I'm gonna skip all the various bullet
points that explain why self-driving
cars make carpool and more attractive
it's sort of you know you can read them
in the papers just gonna bullet this a
list of observations that are sort of
interesting but I think you're getting a
sense all right the second one and this
is I think it's very important and
sometimes overlooked that self-driving
cars will make Road pricing even more
necessary than it is right now so I'm
gonna skip the first one it says it says
why you know why it's good it's
convenient once your self-driving cars
actually road pricing becomes
logistically trivial a self-driving car
has to know where it is at every moment
in time so slapping some payment system
on top of that is trivial but the more
interesting they can from the economics
point of view reason is that you can
when you think what self-driving cars
your thing is you're thinking is oh this
is wonderful I you know I can not when
I'm stuck in traffic I can read news
page the newspaper I can sleep I can do
all kinds of things and they say oh
that's great so now I can drive during a
rush hour I no longer need to try to
beat traffic so that's fantastic well
it's fantastic if you're the only person
doing is thinking like that if everyone
else is thinking the same way then
what's going to happen is that even
without people moving around even
without sort of you know in economics
there is this view that the longer is
the time period the more people adjust
but even in the short run when people
still have live in the same houses work
in the same place as suddenly they lose
the incentive to beat the traffic to
leave either to early earlier than the
rush hour later and
the whole thing will equilibrate to the
point where now instead of being stuck
in traffic for half an hour but driving
yourself you'll be stuck in traffic for
two hours but you'll be reading a
newspaper okay so and the wood and this
would sort of go to the point until can
all the benefits from the self-driving
technology will evaporate during even
more traffic congestion and you know
we're not the only ones worried about
this e 1 musk who of all people should
be and on the other side he's the one
pushing self-driving cars the most is
worried about exactly the same thing so
here is a quote fairly recent a lot of
people but I can sleep no but a but I
think that's I mean if you're you know
I'll just give you an example so on the
right here actually I actually took an
uber here and I was finishing my slide
right so that's not something I would be
able to do if I drove by myself ok I was
answering my email I mean it's really
yeah I mean at least some people are
gonna be much more productive when when
they can be passenger isn't it when they
have to drive anyway so here is a quote
from musk a lot of people think that
once you make cars autonomous that
they'll be able to go faster and that
will alleviate congestion and to some
degree that will be true but the amount
of driving that will occur will be much
greater with shared autonomy an actual
traffic will get far worse right so it's
possible than some really distant future
when every single car is self driving
and they zip around that you know 600
miles per hour maybe that's not going to
be an issue but as long as you have some
service vehicles as long as even like
you know one percent of traffic is human
driven speeds will remain relatively
constant and and you really can have a
lot of gridlock even more than now if
you don't find a way to do it and road
pricing becomes even more valuable ok
all right so that was the second green
era and as I said you know if said if
self-driving cars don't materialize you
know both of those green arrows are gone
but the bottom one remains and this is
probably the most important one if there
is just
one thing you remember from my whole
talk this is the slide to remember it's
very simple but it's something that's
kind it's obvious expose but exactly
like we didn't see this pointed out in
the literature and here is a very simple
observation there is a massive
complementarity between car pooling and
road pricing right so you look at the
transportation literature you know their
journals they do talk about how to
encourage people to carpool they do talk
about all kinds of tolling questions but
we haven't seen this point made
explicitly so I'm gonna give you a very
simple example is based on victory in
1969 you know I'm sure most people in
this room have heard the name victory
but probably in the context of VCG
auctions turns out that victory was also
a pioneer in transportation and this is
really brilliant paper where he builds a
very simple model of a bottleneck it's
not now known as the bottleneck model
where which I'm gonna just draw a simple
picture you have point a you have point
B just that's it all the people are
going in this direction and this road
has some capacity all right let's say
you know 60 cars per minute
and as long as the number of cars
traveling on this road is below capacity
it takes them zero seconds to get from A
to B just for simplicity and then the
moment you have you know 61 cars your
intuition may say Oh things will change
continuously is just like everyone it
will have a slight delay and his shows
that that's not what's going to happen
because people will start trying to beat
the traffic by a little bit right
because if you just depart straight your
ID if you leave at your ideal time
you're going to be one minute late for
work
that gives you an incentive to leave a
little bit earlier and the whole thing
snowballs into it discontinuous jump in
congestion okay and then you can use
this model to analyze kind of micro
foundations of congestion and see how
you that operate you know if you have a
bigger road network again there are lots
of papers thinking about this and we're
gonna just stick to this model the most
the most basic most simple one and just
for the purposes of our example suppose
that you know this road is congested
congested and in the sense that there
are hundred and twenty cars per minute
that wants to go from A to B and I think
everyone is identical everyone is the
same so very very simple okay so you
know in the Vikram model if you put the
numbers you're going to get massive
congestion just like tons of people just
really really huge delay okay
so suppose now in this example
carpooling in all of these apps succeed
on carpooling just becomes incredibly
convenient it's still not as convenient
as driving by yourself and in a
particular taking cost into account
people who still prefer to drive on
their own rather than share the cost of
the car so I'm thinking about the world
where cars are relatively cheap from
people's point of view so suppose that
the disutility from car pooling versus
driving solo is some small Delta it's
positive buts but small well guess what
this massive technological change has
absolutely no effect on anything right
even though there is now you know the
just utility from carpooling is small
I'm still better off driving solo than
carpooling right if you come to me and
say you know why don't you carpool
like well you know I'm better off not
carpooling and like if everyone else
carpool it would be great but I would
still be better off driving solo right
so it's really there is really no so-so
carpooling by itself has zero power here
okay now the more interesting case and
this is what vigorous paper is about is
well I know how to solve this problem
and suppose it but suppose there is no
carpooling so in Vickers paper there is
no carpooling and you say well I know
how to sell how to solve the problem we
should just set tolls at the social you
know just compute the tall's you know
I'm an economist you know when there is
the resource is scary you just price at
that you know marginal just util it all
your standard intuition that you have
for how to price for congestion and here
is something that I think even
economists don't quite realize even
though Vickrey pointed this out if you
do that if you set tolls of the social
optimal level you fix congestion there
is no congestion right that's kind of by
by design but perhaps surprising and
none of the drivers are better off so
what ends up happening I'll get to this
in a second what ends up happening is
that each driver simply pays in dollars
what they used to pay in time okay so
with how much genius drivers the like
just from the drivers point of view the
world did not get better now what
changed obviously the government gets a
bunch of revenues but suddenly you have
all this political economy issues you
know do the drivers trust the government
to use the revenue in a way that
benefits them instead of you know pick
your least favorite government activity
you know depending on your political
affiliation and the sooner the
government is doing that right and
viateur extra talks about this victory
talked about this is a big problem for
tools and empirically we know that all
tolls are very unpopular partly for this
reason now if you think about oh but you
know people have different value of time
some people have you know value time
more some people value time less well
from the political point of view things
get even worse because now you say oh
these are Lexus lanes there's a term for
that and all the poor people have to
stay home and all the rich people are
now you know enjoying their congestion
free riding while all the you know poor
people stay at home okay so it's really
you really can't win this one
and finally the last thing and this is
more technologically it's true yeah but
that's still there you can try to do
that you know good luck we wish which
country do you think will you trust the
garlic in the Bay Area okay all right is
there congestion in Germany well why do
you say of course that why don't you
have tolls that's there is that there is
a flaw in that logic and our customers
you're probably like driving I don't
think you like being stuck in traffic
yeah
there was another head okay so here is
here is another thing and that may even
even if you sort of think about all the
political economy reasons are kind of
secondary I can solve them I'm gonna be
single poor I'm gonna be a dictator and
by the way Singapore is the country
that's kind of on the forefront of
tolling there is still another thing in
Victory's world there are two types of
inefficiency one is congestion that
that's one we talked about but another
one is suboptimal arrival and departure
times right people have their ideal
desired arrival times to work and just
technologically if you have you know the
capacity of 60 cars per minute and 120
people want to get from A to B there is
still left on the table this
inefficiency from some people arriving
too early some people arriving too late
right that's tolls do not solve that
okay so even if you can solve the
political economic problems so now and
this is where kind of the punchline of
the slide comes in suppose we have both
suppose we have this convenient
carpooling right in the first bullet
point and we have the ability to set
tolls optimally so now we're really in
them in this magical world because all
we have to do treat in this example
under these assumptions is to set is to
set the tolls slightly above Delta over
two right because when you have two
people in the car they can share the
tolls and suddenly people and I'm
assuming by the way that each car can
hold two people just for
for simplicity right with the simplest
possible example suddenly everyone is
carpooling and you get you get the
efficient outcome and here's what I
personally really like about this you
know being originally from Russia and
from Germany suppose you don't trust the
government and just assume they're gonna
steal all the revenues right you just
like that's it that your working
assumption right whatever they're having
is our generators going to be stolen by
some oligarch you are still delighted to
be in this world right because what ends
up happening is your soul congestion and
the revenues are actually pretty small
it's just you know delta x to prefer the
double divide by two per person and in
fact I'm better off even if other people
are not yet adopting carpooling because
if there are tools that you know that
are said at the level roughly equal to
my value of time when I'm carpooling
with one other person I can split the
monetary cost and two I can pay half as
much whereas if I'm carpooling and I'm
paying through being stuck in traffic
when I have two people in the car each
of us pays the full cost right so you
can see you can share money you can
split monetary payments in the way that
you can split you know time payment make
sense all right so again this is it's a
very simple point but it's like I think
it I think it's really really important
okay
so I as I promised I'm gonna spend half
of my talk waving my hands and I'm done
with that so any questions about
motivation or this observation that was
a good time to ask
it would just set them high enough so
that everybody's carpooling and being
the maximum well so this is like this is
a doubly evil governmental sir in the
world the world I have in mind yeah the
world of it the world I said that the
caricature I said is the tolls are still
set reasonable intelligent there but
then the revenue is destroyed yeah no
yeah it's I mean it is a quite I don't
have an answer to the question of what
would happen if you have a truly that
the government just not tries to
maximize revenues which is actually not
a crazy question that's what we would
get and with with this is the last kind
of a couple of cents on our paper if you
just privatized all the roads that's the
world where you would be actually not
necessarily horrible outcome but it's
clearly not gonna be optimal yes well so
the problem was though that it's very
hard so if you return the money for the
same people who paid literally well then
you lose all of the incentives but if
you have some kind of redistributed kind
of everyone gets equal it sounds good in
theory it's very hard to do it in
practice right so all the people who are
not who are not driving at all are
getting a windfall right and all the
people who were driving suddenly they
don't get back nearly as much as they're
paying so it's it's not quite yeah it
doesn't feel to work quite as well yes
poor people so basically all the money
so the yes a way we didn't our our
framework you as you will see totally
allows for that and so we could simulate
and answer those types of questions and
we probably will in future work
intuitively what's nice here with
carpool intuitively this is much less of
a problem in the world with carpooling
right without carpooling when you have
rich people and poor people poor people
are just screwed right and that's part
of why tolls are so on pop it was like
look I can't get to work like I can't
pay 25 bucks to get to work it's just
not you know not how much I make here in
this world suddenly you have this extra
margin where reach people will drive so
low and poor people will maybe carpool
with five others but you know there is
still the difference but it's much less
of an issue and by the way if you think
you're just gonna have to take a step
back if you ask me you know on the way
from Stanford to Berkeley I have two
options the current world where I'm
stuck in traffic and you know you saw
the picture right and I have to in text
me you know almost two hours or I can
carpool with five other people and I get
there without traffic you know nine
times out of ten I'll pick that's the
second one right so it serve again again
and this is hand-wavy
so I'll say because it's very hard to
make sure that roughly the same people
get the money as the ones who pay right
so there's a whole bunch of people who
don't drive right so like we're in
Berkeley you know and and they get the
windfall and then people who do drive to
work you don't you don't compensate them
nearly nearly enough then the second
question is how to define the set of
people who is entitled to this payment
back is it people who live in Berkeley
Bay Area California like I think it's is
just very hard to to make sure that
roughly they're the same people who are
driving it's roughly the same I mean you
can try to get it but it's it's tricky
it's not an auction is like you need to
you need to give money to some people
and give and these are not gonna be the
same people but that's not that's not
gonna help
I mean if you think again the ideality
will just charge based on external data
I mean that's V career right and that I
explained so the problem was that one
there's again you get all this revenues
and either the government takes or
someone else right people who are not
carpooling it's still it shifts the
political problem it doesn't solve it
right you're still pitting drivers
against everyone else like that's how to
think about this right even if you do it
a budget in the budget balanced way
you're still screwing drivers and giving
a bunch of money to people who are not
driving so but maybe there is a way to
do that one I think my my preferred near
my ideal world that the revenues are so
small that is just not an issue and
we're just happy to let you know Gavin
Newsom steal it let me let me get to the
model the model actually you know
accommodates non you know static pricing
as well we're not saying that people can
people can own cars our so that's part
of that's not that's not the vision here
right this is the both quote like you
can have governments run cars you can
own cars that's not a that we're not
making taking a stand on this at all
okay I have seven minutes until my five
minute warning and so let me actually
get to the math but again I think I got
my most important slice you know that's
I'm happy about that one saladna very
quickly and run through the model and
the main results and then you know we'll
have more time during those two days to
discuss so here is the model
there's a finite set of writers 1
through m there is a finite set of road
segments right so think of you know
there is some graph of road segments one
through s and it's not just a graph so
each segment identifies a particular
piece of the road and a time interval
right so we discretize time and so it's
a pair road and time stamp each road
segment has a capacity Q s just like in
victory how many cars can pass through
it during that time and a key notion you
know this is matching so you know when
two sided matching you have pairs here
the kind of key element of the solution
is going to be a notion of a trip so a
trip is this abstract object which we
interpret as a feasible combination of
one or more riders and one or more Road
segments right feasible means that it's
just physically make sense right so if
you have one rider who needs to go from
here to here right and the segment would
have to be one of the segments here it
wouldn't make sense to have this rider
matched with this segment right so that
would not be a feasible trip okay
I'm not gonna take questions for the
next five minutes sorry and yeah there
is a finite set of possible trips T all
right it's large but it's finite
now each trip has a physical cost C of T
associated with it right that's the just
a fit where and tear of the car the
gasoline all the things we talked about
and each rider has some valuation V of
em each Rider M has a valuation V of M
of T for each trip that involves that
writer and that's where your include
preferences such as how much you care
about going faster there's a slower
carpooling versus driving solo etc okay
I mean obvious in practice you would
find some parametric form to denote this
but here is just completely apps are
gonna we assume that mine is just enters
quasi linearly right if I get three
dollars I'm three dollars happier for
each M there exist an outside option you
stay home you get there from zero you
don't use on your
versus and in assignment that's the
parallel to the notion of matching an
assignment is a set of trips size that
each rider is involved in exactly one
tripping a okay so just like in matching
it's a set of pairs here is a set of
trips and here there's an extra
constraint that's kind of an overall
constraint assignment a is feasible if
for each route segment as the number of
trips and a that include that road
segment does not exceed the capacity
right so yeah so that's the
[Music]
yeah so that's that doesn't notion of
feasible assignment so that's that's
pretty clear and the surplus of an
assignment that's very cool you just add
up the utility of everyone involved and
subtract the physical costs C of T of
actual moving people around all right
okay so now we want to imprint simple if
we knew everyone's utility functions and
we could just tell everyone what to do
right so that's like the dictatorial way
of get over achieving optimum we don't
want to do that we want to support this
with prices and you know in a
decentralized fashion and there are
gonna be two sets of prices here right
they're different first is price vector
P that specifies the price that each
rider pays for the trip that he or she
gets right so that's what I pay
out-of-pocket but then there is also a
non-negative vector R of tolls specified
by the regulator all right and these
will be used to support the best
allocation and an outcome and this is
this is the solution concept into the
says an analog of an outcome and
matching with contracts and outcome is a
triple APR that specify an assignment
you know who goes where how much they
pay P and the tolls imposed by the
government are alright so what do we
want an outcome to specify well what
would to satisfy well first of all it
has to be feasible we say an outcome is
feasible of the corresponding assignment
is feasible just physically make sense
the second one and this is where -
starts being you know a roll its budget
balanced if the sum of prices paid by
the riders for their trips is sufficient
to cover the tolls and the costs these
are think of this as mostly just
accounting exercises and the
substantively interesting ones are the
next two one we say that in a slight an
outcome is stable if it is not possible
to organize a trip T that makes all the
riders involved on that trip better off
then under that outcome right so it's so
like a free entry condition this is what
allows you to own your own cart right
the government can't force you to
participate in something right so if
someone's oh here's a wonderful plan and
then Leah and I look at this and say oh
given the tools and the cost we can just
carpool together and you know screw that
plan that
would break the stability of the outcome
it is just like instability and pairwise
matching so here it's a bit more
complicated was mining involved now
these three are desirable conditions but
they're not sufficient for what we want
and here is an example suppose you have
a government that goes nuts and charges
a trillion dollars for every segment at
every moment in time everyone stays home
right that's an outcome it's feasible
resource on being used as budget
balanced zero equals zero it's stable
no one can do any better than staying
home but it's clearly crazy right why
why is it crazy
well prices are too high so how do we
formalize that and that's the last
condition we say that prices are market
clearing if the government can only
charge for roads that are at capacity
right if the road is underutilized you
know and here's a theoretical framework
it's literally night knife-edge and
practice would be some slightly more
continuous if tolls if the road is
underutilized you have to charge this
year at all okay so here our first main
result if an outcome satisfies all of
those four properties then assignment a
has the highest possible social surplus
of all the possible assignments so in
particular it's enough to set tolls at
the road level at the road segment level
you don't need to worry about more
complicated combinatorial prices you
don't need to worry about charging
different prices to people who are
carpooling versus driving so low
all you need to do is find such an
outcome now I have one minute left so
I'm gonna give you some bad news I'm
gonna skip the proof combine some ideas
from matching with some ideas from
general equilibrium it's similar to the
in a first welfare theory but it's not
it's actually there is a other the
machinery is different so it's the last
point I want to make open to questions
is well we have a problem and those of
you who are CEA's people here probably
think about this while an issue is a
feasible stable budget balance
market-clearing outcome may fail to
exist here's a very simple example
suppose we have hundred and one cars
oh sorry hundred 1p
and each one of them the numbers are
such they want to carpool with exactly
one other person this is a roommates
problem well you're now going to have a
feasible budget balance table outcome so
what we propose is will propose a
divisible approximation we build a model
where we allow trips to be divisible
formalize that notion and then we a
prove that such a feasible stable budget
balance and market-clearing quasi
outcome is guaranteed to exist and each
one's gonna be socially efficient so can
our plan going forward is to put some
some numbers on this kind as a few in
future papers and try to see how good of
an approximation this is whether it's
get our intuition so that because
numbers are large this is not going to
be too much of a problem so like the
clothes integer solutions are actually
gonna be reasonable but I cannot claim
that I don't have a mathematical proof
of that okay and I'll stop here and now
you know those of you who I know you had
a question which I suppressed sorry
about so the conception of a trip I'm
imagining like it was a set of riders
and drivers so if we have a path like
the car goes from A to B to C to D yeah
and I'm only in it from the B to C
segment you're part of the trip
right so what are the feasibility
constraints on trips though also so the
feasibility that here the feasibility
concern of each individual trip I would
take it as a perimeter right that's
that's something that you as like
someone who's applying this framework
will differ will define right so maybe
like there is some and the number of
people in the car could be a constraint
you can't have more than three people on
the trip at the same time there's a
difference between both riders being in
the car for the entire duration of it so
the reason why I'm not worried about
missing it is yeah exactly trips are
exogenously it's it's it's an exogenous
Lee given set of objects
that's that that's a separate thing
that's who I can talk about this but
that's a so here at the level of each
individual trip like you're I think
you're overthinking it it's like it's
really here just all the possible way
think of the trip is just a way to get a
bunch of people from A to B right with
one car think of think of a trip is kind
of like one car making a trip and then
like there is a full long list of all
the possible combinations of that right
and your and your inch and you're in
charged drivers and bird segments it's
not well I think it's that involves the
signature drivers in the same Road
segments but leaves me at my wrong
destination like I am well yeah okay
fine so that you can have you can have
it specify that that's like it's not
gonna matter much yeah I see your point
we kind of assume that what kind of as
soon as I know where you're going from
and where you're going - yeah it's built
in yeah okay because there is no
incentive so that's the slide
where is it come on yeah this one
because there are no tolls so if you had
tolls and they were high enough to make
sure that we get from A to B without
delay you will see a lot more carpooling
you only gain if everyone garbage would
you achieve the same qualitative
solution if you penalize driving alone
so you will not well so first of all you
will not just mathematically but more
interestingly what you what you don't
achieve by doing that you don't you
don't give people incentives to go
earlier later right so here and this
here you if we're carpooling we can
still go 15 minutes earlier if we don't
really care one way or the other
and if you just do it based on the
number of people in the car then you're
not getting but that but now you're not
really giving incentives for three
people in the car four people in the car
it's like let's put it this way so our
result says like this is the optimal
thing to do so that it's very much an
open question which you know what are
the other things all right so you could
give some sort of other shift shifting
like we're not okay what we're not
claiming is that this is the only way to
do it okay or to get close but where
think this is a logical way to do that's
this utility view of M V V sub M right
so you can put a massive penalty for
arriving late because remember trips
have segments with timestamps attached
to them and so if the last segment has a
timestamp that's later there
your desired arrival time you just put a
big penalty on that well if everyone
needs to be there by 9:00 a.m. sharp
price at that time may be very very high
I mean that's that's how it has to be
things that you mentioned about the
carpooling essentially thank you Tom he
does not make sense because you say
today like the practice becomes four I
know it just means that what will happen
if price that gets very high instead of
carpooling with one other person who
will take a bus right of course the
change they sound like when prices
there's so what I like what our model is
you have interaction going both ways so
when prices get higher people form
different coalition's right it's just
intuitively the higher the prices the
more people are going to have in a car
at some point you get a bus or a train
so we still get to work at time but now
I have a strong incentive to take a bus
okay sorry okay thank you
[Applause]
thank you it's always a pleasure to be
assigned assignments it's particularly a
pleasure at this time it's the first
time I'm actually getting to give a talk
myself this is